Hey everyone, Ryan here, and welcome back to our series on prosthodontics.
Like all my videos, I'm going to be focusing only on the highest deal of things you need
to know for the exam.
And I know we already talked about the basics of occlusion in our second video of this series,
but here we're going to look more into the occlusion for complete dentures, and understanding
a patient's occlusion is critical to making a proper denture.
So if you haven't watched the first two videos in this series, I highly recommend you check
those out first, because I'll be using a lot of the terms in this video that I introduced
in those.
So there are basically three really important measurements to know for complete dentures.
That is VDO, VDR, and inter occlusal rest space.
So the first one we'll talk about is vertical dimension of rest, which is VDR, and it's
shown in yellow in this image.
So the vertical dimension of rest is the distance measured between the nose and chin at rest.
Now sometimes it's measured using other points, but the most stable points of interest would
be the tip of the nose and the tip of the chin.
So those are typically used for measuring the distance.
It's not only the distance between the nose and the chin, but it's at rest, and specifically
where elevator and depressor muscles are in a state of equilibrium.
This is sometimes called physiologic rest position, or PRP for short.
So if you're just relaxing your jaw, if you swallow, and maybe slightly open your mouth,
that's sort of the most relaxed position for you, that would be your vertical dimension
of rest.
And so this is for a dentalist patients, this is for dentate patients, everyone has a vertical
dimension of rest.
And in this position there is usually, if you have teeth, 3 millimeters of space between
the upper and lower premolars, and that number will become important a little bit later.
So let's just say for this patient, when he's at rest, distance between tip of chin and tip
of the nose is, let's say, 10 centimeters.
Alright so VDO stands for vertical dimension of occlusion.
And that's the distance, again, between the nose and the chin, but when the patient is
biting together, and that's where the occlusion comes in.
And that's going to be represented with the white arrow in this image.
So it indicates the superior-inferior relationship of the maxilla and the mandible when the teeth
are occluded in maximum intracuspation.
Remember MI was one of those key occlusal positions that we talked about in our very
first video.
So you can imagine how the vertical dimension of occlusion would be very different if, say,
chin, if the patient has teeth versus if they're missing posterior teeth, or don't have any
teeth at all.
So let's just say for this patient, it's 9 and a half centimeters.
And you can imagine that when this patient bites together, the tip of his chin gets up
to this line here.
So this is showing his vertical dimension of rest, and you can imagine again, if he was
biting together, his chin would get maybe up to this level.
So that would mean the vertical dimension of occlusion, again, is maybe let's say half
a centimeter shorter for this patient.
And so that leaves us with the final measurement.
That's an intraclusal space, and that's the difference between these two distances, that
is VDR and VDO, and it's ideally 2 to 4 millimeters.
And that's where that 3 millimeters comes from.
That was usually 3 millimeters of distance between the upper and lower premolars when
a patient's at rest.
And so we can get this equation that vertical dimension of rest is equal to the vertical
dimension of occlusion when the patient's biting down, plus about 3 millimeters of intraclusal
rest space, which would be the distance between these two positions.
And this is an ideal scenario, so it varies depending on the type of patient you're working
with.
So in our example, we said vertical dimension of rest would be 10 centimeters, and the vertical
dimension of occlusion would be 9.5 centimeters.
So the distance between those two, or the difference rather between those two, would be 0.5 centimeters
or 5 millimeters.
So you may be thinking, well, okay, that makes sense, but what if the distance between the
two is too large or too short and is way far away from this 3 millimeter mark?
So we'll talk about that right now.
So let's say we have excessive VDO, that would be where the intraclusal space is less than
2 millimeters, or maybe even the VDO is bigger than the vertical dimension of rest.
So this would cause a whole bunch of symptoms, excessive display of mandibular teeth, muscles
of mastication being fatigued, and that's a really important one to know for the exam.
Clicking of the posterior teeth when speaking, strained appearance of the lips as you can
see in this image, the patient would be unable to wear the dentures due to discomfort, excessive
trauma to supporting tissues, and gagging.
So this is a whole host of issues if you have an excessive vertical dimension of occlusion.
So this would be if you made a set of dentures for a previously a dentulous patient, and the
dentures are just too tall, and they're causing the patient to have to stay more open than
they would be at rest, and so this is causing a lot of strain on the tissues and discomfort
for the patient.
Now how about the opposite problem, having an insufficient vertical dimension of occlusion?
This would be where the intraclusal space is greater than 4 millimeters, and the patient
has a long distance of closing between vertical dimension of rest and vertical dimension of
occlusion.
So for example, this could be a patient that just doesn't have any dentures and is missing
all their teeth, so they have an extreme loss of vertical dimension of occlusion because
they have no teeth to bite down on.
So this can lead to a couple things, an aging appearance of the lower third of the face because
of thin lips, wrinkles, the chin being too near to the nose, overlapping corners of the
mouth, and all these things that would lead to someone looking a little bit older.
A diminished occlusal force and angular colitis, which is that could be fungal infection, bacterial
infection at the corner of the mouth, and so this is again due to this overlapping corners
of the mouth with insufficient video, and so this folding in the mouth is just a perfect
opportunity for an opportunistic infection like Canada to take over and cause angular
colitis.
Alright so we have all that information, now what can we do with it?
So the CR record is something we talked about again in our previous video, so definitely
check out those first two videos of the series if you haven't already, but for an agentulous
patient the CR record provides the ability to increase or decrease the video more accurately
in the articulator by establishing a radius of the mandibles arc of closure.
Alright so what does that mean?
Well in other words, if the video is incorrect like we just talked about in the previous
two slides, you can change this by mounting the casts using a CR record, which remembers
all about the patient's condyles, the MI record and the MI position is all about the
teeth coming together, whereas the CR, the centric relation record, and that position
is all about the condyles being at home in their fossa.
So by mounting the casts using a CR record and then manipulating the guide pin on an
articulator can lead you to changing the video and so you can do that in order to adjust
if a patient is having an excessive video problem or an insufficient video problem.
And this is just review from our second video, but the face bow again is critical for giving
us information about where the maxilla is relative to the hinge axis that is the axis
of rotation at the temporal mandibular joints.
So the CR record and face bow together again are those critical diagnostic pieces of information
that we need to create and fabricate a proper set of dentures for that specific patient.
Now we also have a certain record called the protrusive record, and this one registers
the anterior, inferior, condyle path in the translation movement of the condyles.
So in other words, when the patient moves the mandible forward, the condyles slide down
their reticular eminences.
This is that translation movement that I've talked about in my occlusion videos.
And so the protrusive record is capturing this dynamic movement of the mandible forward
and down.
So we have this phenomenon, which is definitely going to be tested on the board exam, called
the Christensen's Phenomenon, and it refers to the distal space created between the upper
and lower occlusal surfaces when the mandible is protruded due to downward and forward movement
of the condyles down their reticular eminences, like we talked about with the whole protrusive
record.
So another way to think about this is a posterior open bite is formed as the patient's mandible
slides forward, like you can see in this image.
Their separation or conclusion of the posterior teeth as the patient slides their jaw forward
because the condyles don't just go straight forward, they come down and forward.
And so that's opening up this posterior space.
Now if you're talking about complete dentures, this could lead to possible instability.
And so there's this thing called compensating curves that could be built into the denture
to compensate for that.
And so we're going to talk about that more a little bit later in this video.
It's super cool to think about.
And this is just a sneak peek of how the compensating curve would work.
It's sort of instead of keeping the denture flat across like this horizontal line, you
can curve the teeth back and up as you go posteriorly so that as the patient's sliding
forward, all the teeth remain in contact.
But again, I'll talk about that a little bit more in later slides.
All right, so let's talk about the plane of occlusion and how we can measure that for
a patient receiving dentures.
So the camper's line is an imaginary line from the alla of the nose, that's the side
of the nose to the tragus of the ear, which is that little part of skin that sticks out
from your outer ear.
And so if you draw an imaginary line, that would be your camper's line.
And so if you remember alla of the nose, tragus of the ear, that would be something
that again could be tested on the board exam as could the inter-pupillary line, which conveniently
is just an imaginary line between the pupils of the eyes.
So inter-pupillary, meaning between the eyes or the pupils of the eyes.
So the maxillary occlusal wax rim should be parallel to both of these lines.
So maxillary occlusal wax rim, what's that talking about?
Well I'm going to talk a little bit more about this in the next video, but the occlusal wax
rim is what you would make after taking your impression.
And what we would use to measure the maxillomandibular relations, that's the whole MMR thing that
we talked about again in our introductory videos.
And you would measure the MMR and guide the lab technician where to place denture teeth
in the trial denture.
So this is really important, this is just a nice clipart picture of what a wax rim would
be, patient would try it in, and we'd be able to see where that patient's camper's line
inter-pupillary line would be.
And we want to try to keep that maxillary wax rim parallel to both of those lines if
possible.
And we can measure this with this metal instrument called a fox plane.
Alright so balanced occlusion for complete dentures, it refers to simultaneous anterior
and bilateral posterior contacts, a phenomenon known as tripodization in centric and eccentric
movements to maintain seating of the dentures.
So tripodization is an important concept, and it involves again contacts that are simultaneous
in the front, so anterior contacts, and contacts on both the patient's right and left side.
When the patient's both biting down, that would be eccentric, and when they slide the
mandible around, front, back, sideways, that is eccentric movements.
So we're getting this tripodization where all points of the denture, both front and both
sides of the back, are contacting all at once.
So again that concept of the Christensen's phenomenon is ideally not occurring with dentures
because we want to maintain contact as the patient slides around, so the dentures are
being stable in place, and there's a constant force that's on them at all times.
So that's what balanced occlusion is, talking about having balance between those all different
points of the denture, so that one side of the denture is not getting more force than
the other side, which could cause it to dislodge, the front's not getting more force than the
back, which would cause it to dislodge, etc.
So anterior guidance, however, should be avoided in complete denture occlusion to prevent
dislodgement of the denture basis.
So this is an important distinction here, because we like to have simultaneous anterior
and bilateral posterior contacts in centric and eccentric, however, we don't want anterior
guidance because this could cause dislodgement, this would be, we talked about it in one of
the previous videos, anterior guidance referring to incisal guidance and canine guidance.
So anterior guidance is an umbrella term that includes both incisal and canine guidance.
And this makes sense, right, because anterior guidance is focusing only on the incisors
and the canines, and if those are the only teeth in contact, well, the posterior teeth
would be excluded, and so now we have, we have an unbalanced occlusion on the dentures.
There would be more contact on the anterior teeth than the posterior teeth, and we could
have the dentures flip in dislodge.
So we want to avoid that and instead have a nice balanced occlusion.
So on the balancing side and on the working side, these are terms that are referred to
in my dynamic occlusion video, so I will leave a link to that in the description where we
talk all about this type of working and non-working movement.
So if you'd like to learn more about that, definitely check out that video, I'll leave
a link in the description.
All right, so we had this balanced occlusion concept.
Now let's talk about lingualized occlusion, which is another sort of occlusal scheme.
These are all occlusal schemes used in denture fabrication and tooth setting and tooth position,
and so lingualized occlusion is another one just to be familiar with.
So it's where only the palatal cusps of the maxillary posterior teeth contact the mandibri
posterior posterior teeth, theoretically eliminating destabilizing buckle for specters.
So you probably don't have to know too much about the details of this.
There's all this neutral centric occlusion and all that.
I think the only thing you would need to know for the board exam with lingualized occlusion
is that it's all about here's the upper teeth and the lower teeth, and this is from sort
of a coronal view.
This would be the palatal cusp of the upper posterior teeth and it's contacting in the
central fossa or marginal ridges of the lower posterior teeth, and that is the only contact
that we want in lingualized occlusion.
So the lingual cusp of upper teeth into the lower fossas and marginal ridges being the
only point of contact which could create a very simple and stable force vector to avoid
again.
We're just trying to avoid dislodging of the dentures during function.
So we have balanced occlusion which is all about tripotization and we have lingualized
occlusion which is all about upper palatal cusps being the only point of contact.
And that's really the gist of it, that's the most important stuff I would take away from
balanced and lingualized occlusion.
All right, so before we end the video I'll talk about these Bennett concepts, there's
some distinctions that are important with the different Bennett terms, and then we'll
end talking about determinants of occlusion.
That'll basically wrap up the very complicated and somewhat dry concept of occlusion.
So I'm hopefully helping you understand some of this, I know it's a little bit dry and can
be a little bit wordy, but would mostly focus on the highest yield information for the Bennett
stuff.
So Bennett angle is the angle obtained after the non-working side condyle has moved anteriorly
and medially relative to the sagittal plane.
So let's get familiar with this image because it'll really help us understand these concepts.
So this is an aerial view of the mandible.
We're seeing the two condiles which have been sort of isolated from the rest of the mandible.
And you can see this darker gray part is the mandibles start position and the lighter gray
portion is the mandibles end position after having moved forward into the right.
So the patient is moving the mandible to the right which means that the right side is the
working side and that would mean the left side is the non-working or balancing side.
So the patient is moving to the right that means that the right side is working side and
their left side is their non-working side.
Okay.
So Bennett angle is all about the non-working side.
So for this patient it would be their left condyle since they're moving to the right.
So the Bennett angle is shown here on the left condyle, it's this angle that has been
formed as the condyle has moved to the right and has moved forward.
So remember the standard for Bennett angle is about 15 degrees.
That's sort of the universal standard for setting on that semi-adjustable articulator
that we had talked about before.
Now Bennett's shift is the lateral movement of the mandible toward the working side during
lateral excursions.
I'll go ahead and read the next one as well.
Bennett movement is lateral movement of both condyles toward the working side, basically
temporal mandibular joint looseness.
So some sources use shift and movement interchangeably or use the collective term lateral side shift
to refer to both the bodily movement of the mandible and its two condyles.
So this picture shows both the angle, the Bennett angle which is on the non-working
condyle as well as the shift or movement which is evident on both condyles but Bennett movement
is only evident or the Bennett angle is only on the left movement on both but you can really
appreciate this lateral side shift for the working condyle as the mandible is moving to
the right.
So I don't think there has to be a distinction for your studying on the board exams because
some sources say this is only the shift due to bodily movement and the movement is from
condyles and I've seen it the other way.
So I would just remember angle being for the non-working condyle shift and movement referring
to the whole mandible just moving towards the working side including the condyles.
Alright so lastly here we are determinant of occlusion and so this slide is an awesome
reference slide for you.
I really highly recommend checking this out, pausing the video and writing all this stuff
down, and the factors that favor exclusion that would be no eccentric contacts or the
separation of posterior teeth and the posterior teeth separate quickly when leaving maximum
intercostation.
So these are all the determinants of all the exclusion of factors that favor exclusion.
So you can think about that Christensen's phenomenon, that quick separation of teeth
from each other, these are all things that can be built into a patient's anatomy or can
be controlled based on their teeth with fixed prosthodontics, removable orthodontics, things
that we can control for the most part in order to favor exclusion.
So again this is a great reference slide for boards and I highly recommend you memorize
all of these at your convenience of course.
So the first thing we'll talk about is anterior guidance, again that's that incisal and canine
guidance kind of stuff.
And so in the horizontal dimension that would be a protrusive movement forward we'd want
a steep incisal guidance and that makes sense because a steep incisal guidance will separate
the teeth quickly.
In the lateral direction that would be excursive movement to the right and left we'd want steep
canine guidance because again that will separate the teeth quickly.
Alright cool, so that makes sense.
Now how about for posterior guidance?
Well we have some things that we've already covered and in the horizontal direction again
that's protrusive movement forward we'd want a steep horizontal condler inclination that
would be the condiles sliding down their path along the articular eminences.
In the lateral direction we'd want less bendent movement that's that lateral side shift we
talked about towards the working side.
So we'd want less of that in order to favor exclusion.
For cuspal anatomy we'd want short cusps with shallow inclines and this one may be counterintuitive
at first because we've all been talking about for the most part steep sort of things and
now we're talking about shallow inclines.
But short cusps with shallow inclines, well that was true for the anterior teeth having
steep inclines but for the posterior teeth we want short stubby cusps because then they
will disclude or separate from each other faster.
So we want the steep cusps for the front teeth that can provide anterior guidance but shorter
cusps for the posterior teeth will be able to separate from each other much quicker.
So again these are all the factors favoring exclusion so that would make sense there.
The tooth arrangement is referring to the compensating curves that I mentioned about.
So less curve of speed and less curve of Wilson.
They're both compensating curves and well let's dive a little bit more into those specifically.
So the curve of speed is the anterior posterior curve to ensure loading into the long axis
of each tooth so it's shown in lime green here and as you go back posteriorly there's
more mesial inclination of these bottom teeth.
So you can see how they start sort of straight up and down and as you go back these molars
start to tip more mesially.
So this premolar is like this, the long axis of this one goes here, long axis of this one
goes here and so on.
So they kind of tip more and more mesially and this creates a favorable loading into
the long axis of the teeth.
So that was from the side view.
Now from our coronal front view the curve of Wilson is the medial lateral curve along
posterior cusp tips but to do the same thing to ensure loading into long axis of each tooth.
So now instead of more mesial inclination we're having more lingual inclination as you move
distally.
So that means some of the teeth in the front the premolars are tipped more this way and
then as you move posteriorly they tip more to the lingual and this creates this kind
of smiley face arc in this direction.
So those are our two compensating curves.
So to have less of these compensating curves having more flat across horizontal arrangement
of teeth again would lead to that Christian sense phenomenon you'd have a faster separation
of the teeth.
So you could provide more or less curve depending on what kind of occlusion or disillusion you
wanted for your dentures.
So again having less of a curve and having a straight across occlusal plane will allow
the teeth to separate from each other more than if you had them tilted and sloped.
And lastly we want to talk about the orientation of the occlusal plane and this is different
from the compensating curves because we're comparing the orientation of the occlusal plane
to the orientation of the condler path.
So we want the occlusal plane if we're going for a disillusioned to be less parallel to
the orientation of the condler path.
So let us draw a quick sketch here if we have the occlusal plane let's say it was pretty
flat we had a very minor curve of speed going posteriorly and the horizontal condler inclination
was something like this let's say.
So the condyle is moving down this way and so the teeth would be discluding in this sort
of direction.
So having a less parallel or more perpendicular occlusal plane to the condler path would have
more disillusioned since the condiles will slide down at a steeper angle relative to
your occlusal plane.
So a situation that was like this would exclude not a whole lot because you're having the
condyle slide down at a similar angle that the teeth would slide down each other whereas
if you had something like this where the two angles are more perpendicular closer to being
perpendicular than parallel you'd have more disillusioned.
And on this slide I'm not going to go through it because it's basically just the opposite.
This would be all the factors that favor eccentric occlusion on posterior teeth that is posterior
teeth separating slowly when leaving maximum intercussation.
So this is everything exactly opposite to what we just learned.
So for your board studying you really just have to pick either this slide or this slide
to memorize because as long as you know one of them you know that the other is true for
all of the opposite factors.
So again having more or less of a certain determinant of occlusion depends on the type
of occlusion you want.
Because that patient is if they had a full mouth rehabilitation with a bunch of crown
and bridge work if they have complete over complete dentures it depends based on the
situation of the patient and what they're going for what kind of occlusal scheme whether
you want balanced occlusion whether you want lingualized occlusion and whether you'd want
to favor exclusion or maintaining as much eccentric occlusion as possible.
Alright so hopefully that video is helpful.
I know some of those things got pretty complicated pretty quickly but hopefully having that reference
slide to go back to really help you in your studies.
Thanks so much for watching everyone.
I hope you enjoyed this video and we'll see you all in the next one.